[Musique]
par l' attaque surprise de pearl harbor
les japonais espèrent briser la
puissance militaire américaine et
prévenir d'autres représailles
[Musique]
malheureusement c'est un échec total
les japonais réussit à couler ou
gravement endommagées cette vieux
navires de guerre américains mais la
bataille ayant lieu dans un port la
majeure partie des membres d équipage
est sauvé et seuls deux bâtiments sur
l'ensemble de la flotte sont détruits
même les installations militaires
côtière survivre aux raids aériens de
plus cette violation du territoire
américain unis de pays tout entier qui
déclare la guerre à l'empiré du soleil
levant
en outre la destruction des navires de
guerre américains oblige les us navy à
utiliser ces nouveaux porte-avions comme
pilier de sa flotte du pacifique plus
moderne
les portes
lexington et saratoga tous deux
construits en 1927 et les plus modernes
sont en patrouille au large
lorsque le raid aérien survient ils sont
par conséquent épargné en 1942 le
sistership de lenteur prize et le
yorktown et l'orne est récemment mise à
l'eau viennent compléter la flotte du
pacifique ses porte avions sont
spécialement conçus pour mener des
offensives car ils peuvent transporter
un grand nombre de chasseurs de
bombardier
l'amiral chez star williams limite est
le commandant en chef de la flotte
américaine du pacifique en 1942
en quelques semaines ce brillant
officier convaincu d'une victoire alliée
rétabli le moral des troupes
peu après son entrée en fonction
l'amiral limite décide de mener une
série de raids aériens sur les îles du
pacifique occupée par les japonais
hormis titiller les japonais la
principale raison de ces raids et de
maintenir le moral de son équipage et de
le rendre opérationnel sur le terrain à
plusieurs occasions ça flop a taclé bas
japonaise située dans les îles gilbert
et marshall puis en mars c'est au tour
des îles marcus et wade
ces raids aériens sont importants et les
dommages infligées à l'ennemi au cours
des premiers mois de l'année 1942 sont
considérables
les stratèges japonais redoutent plus
que tout que leur pays subissent une
attaque aérienne américaine
mais ces craintes de vienne d'une
certitude le 18 avril 1942 lorsque seize
bombardier moyens b25 mitchell attaque
tokyo
cette flotte est sous le commandement du
lieutenant colonel james doolittle
plus surprenant encore ses bombardiers
d'un poids de 12 tonnes est prévu pour
décoller depuis la terre ferme
réussissent à s'élever depuis lé pont
d'envol du porte avions us est sportnet
le coeur même de la capitale japonaise
est touchée bien que les dégâts soient
faibles
l'impact sur le moral des habitants est
énorme
le peuple et si effaré que le commandant
de la flotte japonaise
l'amiral yamamoto est autorisé à mettre
en oeuvre son grand plan un dernier
affrontement entre les flottes
japonaises et américaines
mais ce que l'amiral nippon n'a pas
prévu c'est que son grand plan sera bien
vite découvert par l'ennemi dès la fin
du mois d'avril les services secrets
américains sont capables de décrypter
85% des signaux japonais
ce décryptage à lui seul confère aux
américains un avantage considérable sur
leurs ennemis
en effet les services secrets américains
découvrent qu'une importante offensive
est prévu dans le sud ouest du pacifique
les casseurs de code us confirment que
port moresby sera la cible d'une attaque
japonaise ainsi que les îles salomon de
ces deux forteresses
les japonais seront capables de dominer
voir envahir le nord de l'australie
le plan japonais consiste à couper
l'australie des états unis tout d'abord
en assiégeant port moresby
puis en établissant une base aéronavale
sur la petite île de toula guy
dépendante des îles salomon
puis les japonais occuperont des points
stratégiques en nouvelle calédonie à
vanuatu et dans les îles fidji
afin de mettre en place cette offensive
les japonais constituent une force
d'invasion qui comprend une formidable
et ce cadre d' attaque composée de six
destroyers moderne de trois croiseurs
lourds et des grands porte-avions chocat
coup les we can
ces deux porte avions peuvent
transporter jusqu'à 133 avions
la force d'invasion devant se rendre à
port moresby partira de ras bol et la
force d'attac quant à elle partira de
lille de truck appartenant aux îles
caroline située à quelques 1600 km au
nord-est de la nouvelle guinée les
américains réagissent rapidement et
partent à la poursuite des japonais
l'amiral limite envoie une force navale
scindé en trois expéditions dans la mer
de corail
le contre-amiral frank ji fletcher
naviguant sur le porte-avions new york
times en tête de la task force 17 est
chargé du commandement tactique de
l'ensemble de l'escadre
le 1er mai 1942 la tf 17 rejoint la tf
11 sous le commandement du contre-amiral
fitch naviguant au sud des îles salomon
sur le porte-avions lexington
les deux porte avions pouvant accueillir
chacun 141 appareils sont escortés de 5
3 heures et de 11 destroyer ces deux
task force seront rejointes plus tard
dans la journée par une escadre
américano australienne de croiseurs et
de destroyers sous le commandement du
contre amiral john place
[Musique]
le 3 mai les japonais occupent la petite
île de toula guise sans rencontrer
d'opposition
le lendemain ils sont bombardés par des
avions ayant décollé du york tarn
[Musique]
ce raid mené par les américains réussite
a coulé un destroyer et plusieurs autres
navires de taille inférieure
mais les alliés ne pourront plus prendre
les japonais par surprise ces derniers
savent désormais qu'au moins un porte
avions américain croisant dans les
parages
les 5 et 6 mai 1942 les avions
d'observation américain japonais se
cherche en vain
[Musique]
ce n'est que le 7 mai 1942 que les
antagonistes finissent par se rencontrer
les deux camps souffriront tout autant
de ce contact
à la suite de maladresses et d'accidents
peu après 7 heures un avion
d'observation japonais pensent avoir
repéré un porte-avions et demi au
sud-ouest de l'île de guadalcanal
le contre-amiral arts a chargé du
commandement des porte avions japonais
sho kacou et louis kacou lance un assaut
de grande envergure 51 bombardier
escorté par 18 chasseurs 0 quitte les
pont d'envol les navires repéré par les
japonais sont en fait le pétrolier us s
né au chaud et un croiseur des scores de
cible facile
bon
pendant que cette attaque se prépare le
contre-amiral haras apprend que la
véritable 17e escadre américaines
naviguent plus au nord-ouest
tout ce que haras peuvent faire c'est
attendre patiemment que ces avions
reviennent mais les japonais ne sont pas
les seuls à commettre une erreur
à 8h15 un avion de reconnaissance
américain rapporte les positions de deux
porte-avions japonais est de 4 croiseur
lourd juste au nord de l'île 2006 ma
près de la pointe est de la nouvelle
guinée
le contre-amiral fletcher au
commandement du york times est convaincu
d'avoir repéré la force d'invasion
japonaise et lance également une attaque
de grande envergure près de lille
93 avions s'envole du yucatan et du
lexington en réalité l'avion de
reconnaissance us n'a repéré qu'une
force japonaise de soutien composé de
deux croiseurs et de deux destroyers
mais heureusement cette erreur est
réparée par le lieutenant-colonel
hamilton chargé du commandement de
l'escadrille de bombardements du
lexington
alors que le porte-avions se dirige vers
la forge japonaise de soutien hamilton
met le cap vers l'est où il aperçoit une
force beaucoup plus importante
une force de couvertures pour l'invasion
de port moresby sous le commandement du
contre amiral a remote au godo naviguant
sur le porte-avions chaud
les avions américains change aussitôt de
trajectoire au début le show facilement
manoeuvrable réussi à esquiver les tirs
américains mais cela ne durera qu'un
temps et le porte-avions finira par être
coulé
[Musique]
entre temps franck fletcher donne à
l'escadre américano australienne sous le
commandement du contre-amiral créé
l'ordre de contrer la force d'invasion
de port moresby la force de crise est
attaquée par les japonais décollant de
ras bol puis malheureusement par db 26
américains partis d'australie est
prononcée navire pour des bâtiments
ennemis par chance aucune de ces deux
attaques ne lui est fatale
le 7 mai les japonais comme est une
seconde bévue surprenante des avions
japonais patrouillant à l'affût de la
flotte américaine repère le york times
mais le prenant pour un des leurs ils
tentent de s'y poser dix de ces avions
seront abattus
[Musique]
la destruction du show et la présence
d'une force américano australienne au
large de port moresby ainsi que le chef
de la force d'invasion japonaise le vice
amiral inouï et a différé l'invasion de
la ville
tôt le matin du 8 mai 1942 les forces
ennemies finissent par se localiser
mutuellement à la suite de la
destruction du show chaque camp ne
possède plus que deux porte-avions mais
les japonais n'ont que 95 avions
opérationnel contre 118 du côté
américain
peu après 9 heures les forces aériennes
des deux camps d'école ainsi commence la
bataille de la mer de corail
[Musique]
l' attaque japonaise endommage gravement
le york times et le lexington
le yorktown réussi grâce à une manoeuvre
habile à éviter les torpilles japonaise
mais les bombes explosant près du navire
l'endommagent gravement en dessous de la
ligne de flottaison
une autre bombe traverse quatre seront
définies par exploser faisant prendre
sept morts et 33 blessés
[Musique]
le lexington plus imposant et -
manoeuvrable que le yart âme est touché
par deux torpilles ainsi que par
plusieurs bombes et donne de la bande
[Musique]
pendant ce temps les pilotes américains
lancent une attaque sur les porte-avions
japonais
le louis kacou le vaisseau amiral et
dissimulés par des trombes d'eau c'est
donc son sistership le show kacou qui
sera la cible de l'ensemble de la flotte
aérienne américaine
les quelques chasseurs 0 défendant la
flotte japonaise parviennent à maintenir
la première vague de dévastateur
américain à distance pour que leurs
torpilles n'atteignent pas leur cible
mais la seconde vague de bombardiers en
piqué dao tu laisses qui suit connaît
plus de succès le pilote d'un dao tu
laisses le lieutenant john powers a juré
de couler un porte avions ennemis sol
pendant l'attaqué du choca couvent il
descend en piqué pour attaquer le
bâtiment de près lâchant une bombe à
seulement 90 mètres au dessus du pont du
porte avions
l'explosion qui s'ensuit cause
malheureusement la mort du lieutenant
john power dont l'avion s'est abîmé en
pleine mer mais les dommages causés au
pont du porte avions sont tellement
importants que les avions sont désormais
incapables de décoller
d'autres bombes viendront terminer le
travail de lieutenant le show kacou doit
se retirer de la bataille sans
couverture aérienne
le vice-amiral inouye et doit rappeler
ses troupes et interrompre l'invasion
la bataille de la mer de corail est un
succès stratégique pour les américains
mais malheureusement un grave incident
viendra ternir ce succès deux heures
après le retour du dernier avion
américain le lexington est victime d'une
grosse explosion
ironie du sort cette déflagration n'est
pas dû à une attaque ennemie mais le
fait d'une simple étincelle provenant
d'un générateur qui par mégarde n'avait
pas été arrêtée à cause du pétrole ainsi
que des vapeur s'échappant des
réservoirs percer un incendie se déclare
l'équipage m à 24 heures à le
circonscrire
mais les dommages sont tellement
importants que l'équipage doit
abandonner le porte-avions 2735 hommes
seront sauvés mais 216 périront dans les
flammes du brasier le porte-avions est
achevée par une torpille lancée par un
destroyer américain
l'amérique a perdu un porte avions un
tanker est un destroyer alors que chez
les japonais
un porte-avions un destroyer ont coulé
mais du côté américain les pertes
humaines s'élève seulement si l'on peut
dire à 564 marins et pilotes alors que
1074 soldats du mikado ont péri au cours
de la bataille de la mer de corail
le japon a également perdu 77 avions
alors que le nombre d'appareils a battu
du côté américain s'élève à 66 lors de
la bataille de la mer de corail les
alliés réussissent à empêcher l'invasion
de port moresby et par conséquent celle
de l'australie
la bataille de la mer de corail est la
première livrée en pleine mer ou les
deux flottes s'affrontant ne se voit pas
et compte uniquement sur leur aviation
pour abattre l'ennemi
les américains ont rapidement maîtrisé
ce nouveau type de combats navals et
honte à nouveau récidivé un peu plus
tard
en fait pas si tard que ça
à la suite de la bataille de la mer de
corail les amiraux japonais prépare
aussi tôt une autre offensive au cours
de laquelle il espère venir à bout de la
flotte américaine du pacifique une bonne
fois pour toutes
en attaquant l'atoll de midway à l'ouest
des îles hawaï les japonais espère
tromper la flotte américaine du
pacifique en l'attirant pleine mer pour
la détruire
[Musique]
le 20 mai 1942 les stations d'écouté
alliés basée près du pacifique
interceptent un long signal radio émis
en morse envoyé par l'amiral historiques
ou yamamoto à sa flotte
le message est transmis à la combattent
intelligence unit basé à pearl harbor
pour être déchiffrées le message révèle
que la flotte japonaise est sur le point
de lancer une puissante attaque sur
l'atoll de midway ainsi qu'une attaque
de diversion dans les îles aléoutiennes
situées à l'ouest de l'alaska la base
aéronavale de dutch harbor dans les îles
aléoutiennes sera la cible d'une attaque
le 3 juin et la base aérienne de midway
le lendemain
l'opération my l'attaquent de midway y
présente toutes les caractéristiques
d'un plan japonais sa complexité les
diverses hypothèses émises sur la
réaction des américains et l'incapacité
à concentrer leurs forces
malgré ces points négatifs le plan
aurait pu fonctionner si les américains
n'avaient pas découvert ses secrets le
choix même de midway n'est pas justifiée
un des capitaines de porte-avions de
l'amiral yamamoto qualifie me wade
opération impossible et inutile
mais alors que les stratèges japonais
décide des points d'attac leurs plans
sont rattrapés par les événements
extérieurs leur aide
james doolittle lancé sur tokyo en avril
1942 avait mis l'empereur du japon en
danger les généraux et amiraux japonais
savent que la moindre faille dans la
défense japonaise doit être comblé
l'amiral yamamoto met alors au point un
plan pendant qu'une partie de la flotte
japonaise lancera une offensive sur
midway le reste fera diversion en
prenant pour cible les îles aléoutiennes
si les japonais réussit à s'emparer de
midway ce sera une menace pour la base
aéronavale de pearl harbor et obligera à
l'amiral nimitz à reprendre midway
c'est alors que la force japonaise du
pacifique forte de son aviation basée
sur l'île l'attendra de pied ferme
grâce à son piège l'amiral yamamoto
réussir à ce qu'il a raté à pearl harbor
à savoir détruire la puissante flotte
américaine du pacifique
il est persuadé qu'après la destruction
de la flotte de l'amiral nimitz la côte
ouest des états unis sera à la merci des
japonais le président roosevelt n'aura
alors d'autre alternative que de
demander la paix selon les hypothèses
des japonais y sort aux couilles
hamamoto implique la quasi totalité de
la flotte japonaise dans son plan 160
navires de guerre dont huit porte avions
et plus de 400 avions
la flotte est divisé en 5 forces de
combat en tête de la flotte se trouve la
force d' attaque composée de quatre
porte avions est de 225 bombardier
ces derniers devront bombardé midway
avant que la force d'invasion composé de
cinq mille hommes débarquent les douze
navires de transport la force d'invasion
sera protégé par deux forces de soutien
chacune à une distance de 80 km à 950 km
de cette force se tiendra la principale
escadre japonaise composée de cette
cuirasse et son rôle sera de venir à
bout des quelques irréductibles qui
survivraient à l'attack des bombardiers
sachant que la chance n'est pas de ce
côté
chester n'imite mise tout sur les
porte-avions et leur capacité de mener
des attaques de longue portée
il décide de laisser les navires les
plus longs au mouillage sur la côte
ouest américaine afin de ne pas
handicaper la flotte l'amiral divise la
flotte américaine en deux casques forces
de combat la tf 16 former des
porte-avions hornet enterprises et la
tête 17 conduite par le yorktown
le 28 mai 1942 la task force 16 kit
pearl harbor mais la tf 17 prend du
retard en raison de réparations
nécessaires sur le yorktown séquelles de
la bataille de la mer des corail
l'équipage basé à pearl harbor annonce à
l'amiral nimitz que les réparations
prendront encore six semaines
mais ce dernier exige qu'elle soit
exécutée en 24 heures c'est chose faite
grâce au travail acharné de l'équipage
le 30 mai sous le commandement du
contre-amiral frank feltscher le york
times quitte le port une fois en mer il
prend le commandement tactique d2 et ce
cadre vous agirez en calculant les
risques avait ordonné chester nimitz
averti par les services secrets
la flotte américaine atteint midway bien
avant que les sous-marins japonais ait
pu établir un cordon à l'ouest de hawaï
pour repérer l'ennemi
[Musique]
l'île de midway petit avant poste entre
l'état de hawaii et le japon est la
sentinelle de pearl harbor la base
aérienne est en état d' alerte les
américains basés ici savent que quelque
part entre les nuages et l'horizon va se
profiler l'ombre de la flotte nippone
les services secrets les ont averti que
l'attaqué prévue pour le lendemain
la garnison de midway a été renforcée la
veille au soir des forteresses volantes
b17 ont atterri
17les b17 sont sur la piste de décollage
où ils sont approvisionnés en carburants
les bombes sont chargés à bord des
avions et les mitrailleuses sont
rechargées dès que l'ennemi sera repéré
les b 17 seront prêts à lancer
l'offensive
au cours de sa patrouille ce matin là
l'enseigne jack quaid aux commandes d'un
pv y catalina de reconnaissance parcours
les cieux à la recherche de la flotte
ennemie hanover il repère les navires de
transport et les croiseurs d'escort de
la force d'invasion japonaise un message
est aussitôt envoyé à l'amiral qui se
trouvaient à bord du hms york dan mais
ce n'est pas cela qui intéresse frank
les deux chers mais bien la force d'
attaques de porte avions
c'est pourquoi ils envoient les
forteresses volantes attaqué la force
d'invasion
alors que les bombardiers s'élance sur
la piste de décollage le contre-amiral
apprend que l'attak de diversion
planifiée par les japonais a déjà
commencé
[Musique]
tôt le matin même les japonais ont
attaqué les îles aléoutiennes
les bombardiers torpilleur et les
chasseurs 0 du porte-avions rougeau
fonde sur la base aéronavale américaine
de deschacht bord dans les îles du
renard les objectifs nippon ce sont les
réservoirs de pétrole les casernes
l'hôpital et l'église
cependant les pilotes inexpérimentés de
l'autre porte avions de la force
le jauniaux sont portées disparues les
flying box américains avaient repéré les
japonais mais il était trop loin des
navires américains et des bases
aériennes pour pouvoir mener des
offensives efficace
toutefois l'amiral nimitz ne se laisse
pas abuser par cette diversion et refuse
de priver mid wade importante force en
les envoyant au nord
[Musique]
le 4 juin 1940 de la principale cible de
la flotte américaine à savoir la force
d' attaques de porte-avions japonaise
sous le commandement de l'amiral nagumo
zigzag à travers un épais brouillard
ignorant totalement que la flotte
ennemie l'attend non loin de là aux
petites heures du matin
les conditions météorologiques
s'améliorent à 4h30
l'amiral nagumo lance sa première
offensive 108 avions décollent du
porte-avions pour attaquer me dewaele
[Musique]
ils apparaissent presque aussitôt sur le
radar de la base américaine
les hérons sorte de derrière les nuages
et la défense de lille à gives aussitôt
les chasseurs basé à midway prennent
l'air également pour affronter l'ennemi
[Musique]
les bâtiments de l'aérodrome et la
garnison subissent d'importants dommages
mais la piste d'aviation est intacte
quelques avions de transport sont
endommagés mais la majeure partie des
chasseurs et des bombardiers sont en vol
pendant l'attaqué
bien que l'île de midway il ne soit plus
qu'un mur de flammes sur l'océan
l'étendue des dégâts reste limitée
l'amiral nagumo est en mauvaise posture
sa première offensive n'a pas réussi à
détruire la piste déviation comme prévu
cette dernière est toujours opérationnel
il doit donc porter un second coup sur
les conseils de l'amiral yamamoto
il a conservé ses meilleurs pilotes et
ses appareils cat est armé de torpilles
au cas où la flotte américaine
arriverait plus tôt que prévu pourtant
ces avions d'observation leur père
qu'aucun navire us et il doit finir de
détruire la base de midway
mais avant même qu'il ait pu prendre une
décision les américains décident pour
lui
les bombardiers ayant décollé de midway
arrive et attaque side
bien qu'ils ne détruisent pas le navire
ils changent le cours de la bataille
le commandant japonais ordonne que la
seconde vague de bombardier torpilleur
soirée armés de bombes pour la seconde
offensive sur me wade à 7h28 15 minutes
après les ordres commandant japonais un
des avions d'observation nippon repères
dix navires de guerre américains à
environ 200 milles au nord-est des porte
avions japonais
malheureusement cet avion d'observation
japonais avait été catapulté une demi
heure en retard le matin même s'il avait
décollé en temps et en heure voulu il
aurait repéré les navires américains une
demi heure plus tôt et l'aurait signalé
avant que les bombardiers soit envoyée
si cela avait été le cas
l'amiral nagumo aurait certainement
lancer ses avions contre la flotte
américaine et le cours de la bataille et
de l'ensemble de la guerre du pacifique
en eût été changée
l'amiral est à nouveau face à un dilemme
doit-il lancé une offensive contre la
flotte américaine ou se concentrer sur
la tacc de midway
[Musique]
et leur donne deux ne paraît armé les
avions mais une autre question se pose à
lui la flotte américaine comprend tels
des porte avions
ces craintes sont fondées lorsqu à 8h20
un avion de reconnaissance rapporte que
la flotte ennemie compte un navire qui
semble être un porte avions
cette nouvelle n'aurait pas pu arriver à
un pire moment
la première vague d'avions japonais
revient de midway où elle menait une
offensive et doit affronter pour se
ravitailler en carburant les bombardiers
opérationnel devront donc voler sans
être escorté de chasseurs et sont
seulement armés de bombes et non de
torpilles
dès 9 heures 18 les ponts des porte
avions japonais sont remplies d'avion
certains sont réarmer d'autres sont
approvisionnées en carburants les porte
avions sont littéralement des bombes
flottantes à l'insu de son homologue
japonais
franck fletcher lance ses avions et est
prête à attaquer à tout moment
du côté japonais on apprend que le pb y
catalina de reconnaissance a rapporté la
position des porte avions japonais à
5h30 4 le matin même franck fletcher a
envoyé le hornet enterprises mené une
offensive pendant que le yorktown attend
le retour de l'avion d'observation à
sept leur nette enterprises encore à une
bonne distance des porte avions japonais
lance leurs avions cent cinquante deux
appareils en tout les américains savent
que les avions japonais ont rejoint les
porte-avions après l'offensive lancée
sur midway mais ils prennent malgré tout
le risque de lancer leurs avions une
telle distance
ces hommes vont mener une des batailles
aériennes n'est plus décisif de
l'histoire
mais ce que ces pilotes ne savent pas
c'est que l'amiral nagumo a décidé de se
dérouter
lorsqu'il a ordonné de ravitailler ses
avions résultat les cadres rock aérien
de la paix f 16 ont quelques difficultés
à localiser leur cible
[Musique]
à 9h28
les deux escadrille d'avions aux
pilleurs américains ayant décollé de
laure net survole la flotte japonaise et
attaque en piqué
dès 9h45 une autre vague de bombardier
torpilleur quitte l'inter price étudiés
atteints la flotte japonaise suivie
d'une autre vague parti du yukon à 10h15
[Musique]
les pertes côté américain sont élevés
les chasseurs et la défense
anti-aérienne des navires japonais
abattent un bon nombre d'avions ennemis
seuls 4 des avions ayant quitté länder
prize reviennent les pertes du hornet et
du york times sont également lourde
et ceux qui reviennent doivent encore
réussir à poser leurs avions endommagée
sur les ponts mobiles des porte avions
ce pilote par exemple n'a pas eu de
chance le capitaine de corvette
mccluskey scrutent le ciel étincelant du
pacifique au nord-est de l'île de midway
il est en tête d'une escadrille de 33
bombardier de l'inter prize et il est
perdu
il doit absolument prendre une décision
il n'a rien trouvé là où ils
s'attendaient à trouver l'ennemi et ces
avions vont bientôt devoir faire
demi-tour pour ravitailler mais le
capitaine mccluskey a une intuition et
décide de poursuivre ses recherches
un peu plus vers l'ouest cela finit par
payer l'amiral nimitz qualifiera par la
suite ce choix comme étant la décision
la plus importante de la bataille
quelques minutes plus tard le capitaine
mccluskey repère le sillage d'un
destroyer ennemis et le suit peu après
10 heures
il aperçoit enfin les porte avions
japonais les premières vagues de
bombardier américain qui venait de
lancer une offensive avait subi de
lourdes pertes
la plupart des dévastateur peu maniable
avait été abattu par des chasseurs 0
mais cette première attaque avait permis
à l'escadrille de mccluskey dette sur
les lieux sans se faire repérer
rejoint par 17 bombardier de yorktown le
capitaine n'aurait pas pu arriver à un
meilleur moment
les ponts des porte avions japonais
contiennent près d'une centaine
d'appareils
il se prépare à lancer leurs propres
offensive sur les porte-avions américain
tous sont chargés d'explosifs et de
carburant à un indice d'octane élevé la
moindre étincelle
les transformeraient littéralement en
enfer flottant
alors que les porte avions japonais se
positionne dans l'acte du vent pour
lancer leurs avions 50 bombardiers
américains tombent du ciel comme des
faucons fondant sur leur proie
[Musique]
les premiers tirs transforme les porte
avions accueilli gaga et sorriaux en de
véritables aux torches flottante comme
le raconte un marin japonais
j'ai d'abord entendu le terrible
grandement des bombardiers puis
l'explosion d'un tir direct
il y à une lumière éblouissante puis une
seconde explosion encore plus puissante
que la première
[Musique]
on
en quelques minutes la majeure partie de
la première flotte aérienne japonaise
est anéanti le quatrième porte avions le
i rio a échappé à l'attaqué et tente une
contre-offensive désespéré à midi le et
riou lens et avion contre le new york
times
[Musique]
au cours de cette offensive le yorktown
tente désespérément de manoeuvrer mais
il ne parvient pas à éviter plusieurs
coups directs
[Musique]
on peut voir sur ces images comment se
porte avions malgré sa taille change
rapidement de cap grâce à ces machines
[Musique]
on peut voir aussi les effets d'une
bombe explose en tout près du octane
regarder à gauche sur votre écran
comment l'avion sur le pont et secouer
le yorktown lutte difficilement pour
survivre aux attaques des bombardiers
mais en vain
[Musique]
à 17 heures l'amiral lens et avion
depuis le hornet enterprises leur
mission en finir avec le hyrule
[Musique]
l'offensive américaine prend les
japonais au dépourvu une fois encore
leur avion sont sur le pont d'envol
car il se prépare à lancer une attaque
aérienne sur les porte-avions américain
encore opérationnels à la tombée de la
nuit
[Musique]
quatre tirs directs font de ces ponts un
mur de flammes
le hir you subi de lourdes pertes et ne
pourra être réparé
[Musique]
au cours de la nuit du 4 juin alors que
les équipages du hornet et de
l'interprète préparent leur avion pour
la bataille du lendemain les
porte-avions sorgues et gaga commence
leur land décembre dans les eaux de
l'océan
[Musique]
alors que le soleil montre ses premiers
rayons le 5 juin 1940 de la flotte
américaine apprend que le hiryu brûlant
encore telle une torche sombre
rapidement
peu de temps après les américains sont
informés que le dernier porte avions
japonais
le haka guy a subi le même sort que les
trois autres quatre des meilleurs porte
avions japonais ont été détruits
[Musique]
le 6 juin ils seront khouya ma moto
donne l'ordre à l'ensemble de la flotte
de se retirer mais les avions américains
auront tout de même le temps d'attaquer
deux croiseurs japonais l'un sera cool
et l'autre sera gravement endommagés
[Musique]
sécurité montent à bord du hms york
tonnes pour réparer les avaries mais peu
de temps après le porte-avions sera
torpillé par un sous marin nippon et
sombrera
[Musique]
ce même jour les japonais accostent les
îles deux atouts et kiska appartenant
aux îles aléoutiennes et abritant
seulement une station météo ces deux
îles à l'extrême ouest des aléoutiennes
sont tellement secondaire que le
débarquement japonais rap eu de
conséquence du côté américain
à un tel point que les américains et
leurs trous qui ont eu connaissance du
débarquement japonais au bout du
quatrième jour n'ont entrepris aucun
effort immédiat pour rejoindre lille
alors que les deux camps considère la
bataille de la mer de corail comme une
victoire celle de midway ne fait aucun
doute
les etats-unis ont détruit la principale
force d' attaque japonaise composée de
quatre porte avions d'un croiseur lourd
de 3 122 avions et de près de cinq mille
marins et officiers
[Musique]
la flotte américaine du pacifique loin
d'être détruite comme l'amiral yamamoto
l'avait promis vient de gagner une
bataille remarquable qui plus est comme
cela a souvent été le cas dans
l'histoire des guerres les américains
ont remporté une victoire face à un
ennemi largement supérieures en nombre
les forces japonais est compromis par
une stratégie compliqué des erreurs
tactiques et de la déveine alors que les
américains bénéficie d'excellents
services secrets d'une très bonne
organisation navale d'un excellent
commandement tactique et surtout de
beaucoup de chance
malgré la destruction d'un porte-avions
237 appareils et de la perte de 307
hommes les américains ont changé le
cours de la guerre du pacifique le japon
ne peut plus prendre le risque de
sacrifier une grande flotte face à une
flotte d'action et sera désormais sur la
défensive
lorsque le japon aura fini de
reconstruire sa marine la flotte
américaine sera déjà devenue la
puissance intouchable que l'amiral
ils sauront coup yamamoto redoutait tant
[Musique]
oh